seasonal
[Music]
okay now I'm in now now he's joined the
podcast okay
[Music]
welcome back to the quarter digital
podcast everybody I hope you're having a
great day I was playing an ominous song
Because an ominous thing has happened
here at Corridor Digital and I've got
Sam Matt and Nick here with me to talk
about it so
um if you guys don't know
last Thursday
a crime was committed
a crime we got full crime
yes
but a crime nonetheless cyber crime well
it is it is prosecutable if you caught
the right person
it would be prosecutable because there
was Financial damage that was done yes
but the chances
the chances of that yeah yeah I mean are
very low that's the problem with cyber
crime
yeah so we were hacked for those of you
who don't know we were hacked our entire
our entire we'll just start with what
happened our entire channel was taken
over by a hacker uh they privated all of
our videos and they posted a
cryptocurrency live stream uh which uh
and then they changed our name and of
our Channel and it took us about five
days to put all the pieces back together
um so that's what what happened uh and I
I'd like to just you know get some
initial thoughts and then kind of go
over the actual crime as it as it
occurred as we know it thoughts yeah
that's a cluster [ __ ] that's what that
was that's my thought I'm very much a
cluster [ __ ] wasn't that seemed like a
normal Thursday yeah exactly yeah just
any other Thursday
hey boys you want to react to some clips
yeah that sounds like a great idea what
could go wrong Nick came in and his
birthday in stocks everything was normal
I did yeah I had a breakfast burrito
ubered to the studio because it was
gonna be one of those great days you
know yeah yeah we wanted to start it off
strong yeah and uh and then then the
worst happened to him the worst happened
yeah and you know what we didn't we
didn't think it would happen to us it
could never happen to us well I thought
it was so funny I thought we were on
purpose I thought was so funny so so
obviously someone got the login
credentials through who knows
but but we'll explain that yeah but what
was so funny is that truly when it comes
to like the amount of maliciousness that
was involved here
like
it was actually pretty low in the sense
that I immediately just was like oh I'm
still logged into the channel and so I
just like [ __ ] around for like five
minutes and like renamed their live
stream to like I'm dumb whatever you
know and like I was like wait a second
like yeah we are hacked but like we're
totally okay like all the videos are
still there yeah they like delete him
they didn't delete anything they just
privated them to like promote their
stupid crypto stuff which I guess thank
you if you're watching this for not
deleting yeah we will not be thanking
these people Nick
they damn it they created thousands of
dollars of financial damage to our
company thousands and thousands
thousands of dollars of course I'm just
saying like this isn't like hey thanks
for not thanks for just shooting me in
the leg you know it's like yeah thanks
for not murdering me I'm thank you it's
still attempted murder you could still
classify it anyways
yeah yeah
um so they got what they had what
happened was they got a whole of a
password from a company email
and that email
didn't when they logged in using that
password they tried three times we have
a record of how many password attempts
were taken
and we have the IP address
they must use the VPN it was a VPN in in
Europe
um and uh they they tried to log in
three times and when they logged in from
uh with the peculiar thing is that they
logged in from a VPN that had never or
sorry not from a VPN from a
um
what I'm blanking on the word IP address
yeah IP address
um that had never been logged in to the
the account before and that did not
trigger two-factor authentication oh
which is the weird thing about it weird
so and then Kim also
Christian didn't Kim say something about
how they used a Russian word or a
Russian name or there was something that
indicated that was the email address
that's what it was yeah huh right okay
yeah so then they changed it to a
Russian domain so a couple curious
things going on here number one they
were able to somehow skirt by two-factor
authentication on Google which is pretty
good you know um it's like anytime
you're logging in from a new IP address
that the
account doesn't recognize it immediately
pings pings the phone that authenticates
that login it did not do that and then
um
then there was the email uh that they
changed to and then they didn't the the
other thing Sam is and you just pointed
this out but they didn't do anything
like truly malicious as in delete all
the videos you know try to access
Revenue you know things like that
all they did was effectively go on and
put this time stamp of this live stream
on the platform which you know if you
look at that company microstrategy they
have
like they already have a presence so I
don't I I don't think it was them
because that just really wouldn't make
any sense at all you know it's like hey
let's go hack
YouTube channels and then post our thing
on there when we already have a presence
online only just to what undermine our
credibility that doesn't make any sense
at all and so then I looked into this
and this this particular type of attack
so the weird thing was as soon as I
contacted our YouTube rep he immediately
knew not only the type of attack but
also in particular what they were
posting and and then I dug into it
further and they've done this they've
been doing this for about two and a half
months on the platform across channels
how many other channels have been hit by
microstrategy wannabes
I I couldn't sorry I couldn't get an
exact number
but it is enough where even the people
that uh our rep has as you know uh
creators other people that he has have
been hit by the same attack and I found
numerous other channels that had posted
hey I got hacked here's what happened
microstrategy same exact protocol
so
it's it's just a bit too like
coincidental and like not
I guess nefarious enough for me to think
that it's somebody that's doing it for
something for themselves personally it
seems like what's happening and this is
speculation but it's it it does have
some circumstantial evidence
I think what's happening is something
somebody like you know the Russian
government or or some other form of
organization like that
is
hiring out people to basically test
the Security on YouTube and they're
doing this in because they're doing it
in the exact same way
and what exactly would be unless it's
somebody that's just I mean it could be
the Simple Theory somebody's just out
there and they're doing it for their own
jollies but well but but also wasn't
there like a link that they were
directing you to for the free freaking
ethereum or something and like yeah
because on the outside it appears to be
like a like a pyramid scheme promotion
type situation where they're like
because like there was a lot of people
who watched that stream on our Channel
yeah yeah it said are you yeah yeah it
was it was a crazy amount of Life yeah
because everyone got a notification
about it 300K 300 000 wow like nuts
which also I'm like wait a second why
don't we use that feature
but seriously well we're gonna win son
of a dungeon comes out oh yeah but like
seriously uh it is yeah so it seems like
this pyramid scheme on the onset but but
what you're talking about Jake with like
the larger scale of it it's it's I mean
there's a valid point to that because
they also you know this is they've they
did this before the 2020 election they
they were hacking into you know it was
Twitter it was Facebook there's
documented bipartisan evidence of this
from the Congress that shows hey they
created thousands and thousands of fake
accounts to you know to basically
so Discord amongst amongst the American
public and it worked um yes and it
definitely worked
um and so it's just I don't know you
know that's I'm just like kind of
putting two and two from my sort of
layman ignorant like perspective but
just seeing the circumstantial evidence
and seeing you know like how
we were in the 21st century like there's
this is the kind of stuff that that goes
on you you hire out a contract agency
you know they they how else would you
get around two-factor uh authentication
protocols too if you weren't if you
didn't have some more
pretty sophisticated tools at your
disposal it seems it seems weird because
that IP address had never touched our
server before yeah I think it's called
like a Sim hack and that's how you get
around it normally where basically uh
you're you're faking a phone you're
you're taking like a like a bugged SIM
card and using that onto a phone and
that way you can connect someone else's
phone number
and so that's it's it's it's it's kind
of common actually but okay yeah but at
the same time
if it they didn't even
have to go through the two factor for
this hello everybody it's that time in
the podcast where we play a little game
um this time I've got uh just a classic
college dictionary here courtesy of
today's sponsor story blocks where you
give me a word and I tell you if there's
anything on storyblocks that might be
related to that word because storyblocks
is your One-Stop shop for all your stock
asset needs but what does that mean Jake
well let's pick a word and find out
pasture there we go there's a good one
pasture do you think you could find high
quality 4K images of pastures on
storyblocks yes you could you could also
find uh I don't know stock images you
might even be able to find audio assets
like cows or other pasture animals that
you might need to use for your videos so
that would be real convenient they also
have music let's let's find a good music
One give me another word solo that's a
good word do you think you could find a
great Acoustic solo
team hey that's a great one be because
with storyblocks they have a bunch of
different subscription plans that are
there to fit your situation so maybe
you're part of a creative team and you
want to talk to your team leader about
an Enterprise plan so that your whole
team can get story blocks well they have
that they also have the unlimited
all-access plan which is our favorite
over here at Corridor Digital which
gives you the ability to download as
much as you want and use it in whatever
you want because it's all royalty free
let's see if we can find royalty
monarchism royalist a supporter of
government by Monarch okay I don't think
that's what they mean by that but um I
think what it does mean is that you
don't have to pay anybody a dime just
because you're using an asset from
storyblocks and that's a great part
about it head on over to storyblocks.com
corridorcast or just click the link in
the description below to get started
today that's storyblocks.com
corridorcast once again huge thanks to
them for sponsoring this podcast and
making it possible and thanks for
playing this little game with me uh now
let's get back to the podcast
right well nothing nothing pinged on the
person's phone
that they you know where they where the
two-factor authentication would have
happened yeah
um so it wasn't like they were in that
person's phone and then you know they
clicked through themselves
yeah
yeah it's super strange
yeah it is strange um and so then what
happened was you know like Sam said he
logged in he still had access to
everything so we immediately
booted every login from the channel
immediately shut everything down you
know obviously changed all the passwords
and the logins and all that stuff uh a
hundred times over and then
um
we told we told that we had told YouTube
at that point and they have a protocol
for this which is interesting because I
don't know if
we would have been better off just like
not telling them I mean part of the
things yeah yeah because
but the thing is is that I'm pretty sure
the amount of viewers who flagged the
Stream
yeah was enough to trigger YouTube's
like auto shutdown process that's what
happened and then it got shut down
anyway that's that's yeah that's what
that's what happened before YouTube took
over that happened first
yeah which so either way we're [ __ ]
because they sent us they sent us an
email about an hour after the stream
went up that terminated our account yeah
yeah and they said it for violation of
community guidelines yeah exactly which
is because of the flagging of that
stream exactly and so it's like
regardless of the yeah no matter what we
would have done this channel would have
basically gone offline
and the other thing is if this is a more
sophisticated attack where there's you
know high level things going on where
they're attacking you know well-known
platforms like YouTube Facebook Twitter
Etc then it is good that the YouTube
team got involved because then they what
they did is they scrubbed they shut
everything down and then they spent
three days scrubbing the entire Channel
figuring out exactly what happened
um and where the logins came from and
all they collected all that stuff so my
uh my assumption is that they then are
you know taking this and then you know a
company like that size with that kind of
numerous attacks probably you're working
with the FBI to
you know put together at least an
Evidence package of of what's going on
um so it's good yeah it's good an angry
letter to the Russian government yeah
do they have any theories about I mean
if this is a widespread thing it's like
do they have theories about where these
attacks are coming from so this is where
the corporate
firewall yeah it happens to us is
because they don't tell us that stuff
um so I asked I asked but of course you
know I I didn't get any
any response back on that um in
particulars because
you know they they try to keep that
stuff private
um but yeah it was it was pretty crazy
um and you know we we've been hacked
once before uh in 2017 when um we were
with Studio 71 and Studio 71 was hacked
it was a similar thing they took over
our Channel they rebranded it uh I can't
remember if they posted videos or live
streams all the thumbnails were changed
and the titles were changed that's right
yeah they changed all the thumbnails
yeah I forget what was the well we don't
have to say their name but it was like
some gaming thing I don't know yeah let
me also yeah kind of blocked that out to
be honest yeah let me let me let me see
if I can find that quick
uh yeah what did they change the
thumbnails to
dude I don't even remember it was yeah
YouTube got hacked so did we this yeah
from April 13th 2017.
I forget we have documentation every day
well the crew works on a new Corridor
video Studio 71 got hacked and caused a
lot of Chaos
let's see
um yeah well it was very violating man
just knowing that you have access to
everything yeah especially I mean for
the person who they actually got oh are
mine hashtag are mine remember this yeah
our mind hey it's our mind don't worry
we're just testing your security please
contact us for more information oh
contact our mindteam gmail.com our
mind.org the biggest hack in YouTube
history
sick dude so these hackers were just
self-aware hackers just kind of doing it
for the walls yeah that's why when Sam
renamed the stream the other day I
thought it was just the hackers being
little shits you know like yeah hackers
because we're [ __ ] you know it's a
deserved [ __ ] yeah I was like I should
have renamed it please don't report our
Channel
Nick in five years when we're hacked
again dude that would make more people
report it yeah that was back when the
channel was called Sam and Nico and it
had 700
000 and one seven hundred and one
thousand subscribers wow
it is like a little time capsule
yeah I wonder if this will be like a
little time capsule too okay so the
theory right now is Russian government
um I mean that's that's my that's my
loose Theory man but that's that's what
they've been doing they've been well
it's a Russian I don't know so I mean
the thing is the Martian government
literally has state sponsored like like
outward like black hat hacking it's
right it's like it's very well
documented interesting yeah do you not
think it was like for personal monetary
gain though like were there were there
links something that yeah and the
description was there like like were
they trying to access people's uh like
wallets crypto walls they might have
been they might have been I don't know I
didn't watch the stream we shut it down
immediately from the government that's
what they hear me yeah
sure it seems more like that it seems
more like they're just posting that
exact same thing so that there's a
there's a a a there's a record that's
exactly the same to say hey we did it
here we did it here we did it here it's
all the same as if you're packaging it
together to then present it to somebody
else to be like hey this is what this is
what our research learned okay that's
what it seems like yeah I don't know
obviously I don't know none of us do
anything but still yeah yeah I feel like
if you're really going to make some
money out of it or wanted to get more
gain there's probably something more
lucrative you could have posted too
other than like some totally okay
tips why wouldn't you try to like
reroute the you know the bank or
something like that or like you would do
something with financials like if you're
in it for personal gain there's a lot of
other things you could do you know
manipulate it in a more subtle way put
links in the description instead things
like that that might not be caught right
away where if you're fishing for like
people to to hook that would be a lot
more effective which is why this yeah
which is why I don't think it was that
but you know my mind went to like when I
first saw it and I saw they were
shilling cryptocurrency
when we like 10 minutes later we looked
up that okay this crypto company the CEO
who's on like the guy who was talking he
like stepped down a couple weeks before
because he lost a crazy amount of money
with bad Investments so like where my
mind went was this is a last-ditch
attempt by some like someone who's
invested in this crypto like spread
awareness and creative virality by
hijacking you know Channels with reach
so that they can you know hype it up and
you know try to bring the freaking price
up so they can sell and that's not an
invalid Theory by any stretch it it but
yeah
reaction
just like some desperate attempt like
you know to salvage this Burning crypto
coins so they could just like sell it
and not take such a loss that's a more
fun story classic pump and dump that's
the thing with that though is that like
that's very timely and you know like
generally with the method they use to
get to the channel it was probably some
sort of fishing situation
um and that's one of those things where
you know you know you go fishing you
can't tell the fish to bite the hook you
just gotta sit there and you know yank
when it happens you know it's not it's
it's something that's hard to time yeah
and since it's been happening for the
last month it's been happening for two
and a half months yeah as far as I
understand two and a half three months
but that does line up with when did the
CEO step down
let's see Michael let's do something
sailor
Michael step down
it's quite a name was it a specific coin
or was it okay this is from August 3rd
this is from August 3rd and as far as I
understand this hack has been going on
since the middle of June okay yeah
but maybe he's maybe he was trying to
get ahead of it you know I don't know
[ __ ] the Russian government [ __ ] those
guys depending evil they're corrupt it's
Chris Tucker Chris Tucker's theory of a
crime from rush hour too he's like
whatever crime there is there's a rich
white man behind it so maybe Michael
Saylor is lurking in the shadows like
you know yeah he's in Russia now yeah
hiring the Russians know but I don't
know yeah yeah it's um
yeah they've just
they've just done some some real shady
things obviously in addition to the most
obvious with with the invasion of
Ukraine obviously very shady so sketch
dude yeah that's beyond sketch that's
I'm sorry I even used that word that's
beyond yeah don't you hate when you do
something embarrassing and then double
down on it do you say face oops war
crimes oopsies yeah yeah I don't I don't
even want to joke about that because
yeah yeah there's people dying over
there every day
um but yeah so that's what we know and
then we were able to get uh things
turned around uh and then by Sunday
we had access again
um but there was a few days in there
where Friday and Saturday
where we were just sort of floating in
The Ether without an account yeah
um making very passionate posts about
our website that's for damn sure yeah
thank God for that website right you
know well you know what though it was
serendipitous to have that and and it
and it did show that hey one of the
reasons why we wanted to do the site
in addition to obviously being able to
do whatever projects we want is to be a
little bit less impacted if things like
this happen
and and that's exactly what it did
um because even still like we're not
we're not going to get Revenue data
until tomorrow to see really how this
yeah how this is impacted
um so
yeah then we and then I spent all day on
Monday
going through a thousand over a thousand
videos
and Nick you would have been proud there
was some old like brand Integrations and
stuff like buried in the buried in the
sedimentary layers that I was able to
delete yeah
um take them out back so I yeah I took
him out back you know
um I cleaned them up
and now um and then I just checked every
video made sure it was public and it was
monetized and all that stuff and it took
me all day wow and we're still waiting
on our check mark too
yeah we're not available
yes he hangs him on his wall yeah good
Jesus Christ
um yeah and then randomly like Monday
and Sunday we're getting like these
random videos just made live like the
freaking yeah and patreon uploads and
like for like five years ago I don't
know how that happened I think it's just
because the the system just went ah yeah
because I was like too many videos yeah
I was batch publishing you know numerous
videos but I I was also I was I would
triple verify the videos that I was
about to publish to make sure that none
of them that I was about to publish had
not ever been published before and for
some reason three videos
randomly published that and went live as
if they were new videos
and I don't know how that happened I
have no idea
um so I guess it's just one of those
things when you're batching a thousand
videos one of them just screams out and
glitches
um
so yeah that was uh those have been
pretty intense few days
um learned some lessons for sure it's
intense for us too because like we
weren't sure if like how much the heck
like how how far that bled through into
our accounts like how we had to change
know where the breach came from at all
so yeah like there there was a full
company-wide like switching passwords to
although the two-factor clearly doesn't
work but not in that specific case but
uh we definitely two Factor
authenticated everything and
yeah yeah that was a big deal
yeah man and maybe they're listening to
this right now trying to get more
information you know who knows
but if you're one of those people who's
out there doing that
there's really no excuse It's like
scammers you know I'm sure that every
scammer who works in the scammer call
center has an excuse about what they're
doing and why they're doing it but there
is no excuse it's wrong you know it's
wrong stop doing it
do something else with your life
now they just like that thrill they love
the thrill of the crime that Rush yeah
yeah the rush
addictive man yeah was it you Sam
no I just listened to a lot of like
hacker podcasts wait really all the same
it's all like hey I'm just bored and I
want to do this for fun and then they
hack something and they're like
sick and then and then they basically
just like try and one-up themselves each
time until it's like status like hey I
hacked this channel it's not even like
status it's just like the thrill of like
you know sneaking in somewhere and
rummaging around and taking something
and leaving you know it's like that's
all it comes down to
crazy wow internet kleptomaniacs yeah
seriously seriously guys
yeah so
anyways um yeah we'll uh we have another
video about this coming out that'll be
out by now it's on crew cuts so if you
if you did join uh the quarter digital
platform as a result of the hack you got
a great crew cuts episode coming for you
oh yeah um
courtesy of Jonah he turned it into a
true crime scenario
um and I'm very excited to see the drama
that plays out uh you know and and I'm
really excited for if people turn on
each other hopefully there's some
moments like that
that's always some wild things yeah we
went back to the stone ages there for
Apollo Justice
yeah I think we
you know I think our response was pretty
pretty calm and collected yeah so yeah
good job everyone yeah nice job yeah I'm
freaked out we were we were pretty yeah
no no one freaked out minimal
um yeah but you know if they have done
this across numerous channels the
financial damage is probably
you know it's hard to it's hard to say
for sure but it's it's definitely into
the class a felony
category which is basically if you get
caught you can go to jail for Life
effectively oh wow uh 15 20 years
um so hopefully hopefully that does
happen
yeah but that's the thing you don't hack
someone in your own country because
that's the only way no of course not
you're prosecuted yeah right right it's
like once it's overseas it's like damn
it's like [ __ ] you're [ __ ] you're
[ __ ] there's too many people out there
too many IP addresses
countries that cooperate especially if
it's happening in Russia is like they're
like someone hacked it yeah we don't
give a [ __ ]
well yeah they're not they're not
helping anybody right now they're just
on an island
um but anyways
um I think we can move on from this
topic there's another thing I want to
discuss
really what's your subject oh do you
yeah it's it's your freedom Matthew oh
my freedom that's specifically my
freedom it's personal freedom oh really
why me is it in Jeopardy you're free now
you've come oh yeah
oh it doesn't feel like freedom to me uh
because we're not done
yeah Matt was in Netflix jail yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah dude but uh you know they
had a tennis court it was nice it was
like it's one of those like white collar
like rich people jails you know okay
yeah yeah they're good this guy's not
gonna he's not a he's not an escapee
threat he'll be fine
to do that man so the second episode of
punch for punch is out it is it is it is
a thousand people know that already yeah
yeah the first one was amazing first it
has like 500k views yeah yeah which is
really cool I mean that's like
okay our push worked but then the second
one dropped on Monday which is kind of a
random time
yeah yeah this is on the still watching
Netflix Channel by the way if you'd like
to just kind of odd time to drop it but
we don't have to get into that I don't
have to get into the details of like how
you plan yeah
you know we don't know yeah everyone is
familiar with that you know I'm sure
it's Netflix
they're big they're big boys people
watching things less on Mondays than
they do on you know weekends or Fridays
you know you know but uh other than that
the the other issue is uh it seems like
when we made our video you know on the
and posted it on the crew channel that
also directed a lot of traffic over
there yeah so not doing that for a day
shift might not have helped so Nick and
I were having this conversation earlier
today
um about the merits of of doing more of
those episodes if they if they asked and
um
I think there's a couple things but I
mean the first thing is okay
what was great about it for us
was that we got to expand a network of
people that we got to work with and we
got to do some cool ideas that we hadn't
been able to do before
and of course we got to do it you know
with a with a production budget that
wasn't our own so it was a good chance
to like experiment with the format and
you know obviously you're beholden to to
the client but the question is like
would we do that again
if they asked
I mean and
I don't know man well so Nick Nick I
think is into the idea
dude I'm into the idea I'm all in I'd do
it again it was fun it was a good time I
preferably on the on the streaming
platform yeah by the way yeah right
that's that's actually the that would be
the main motivation I think that would
be the main motivation to do it because
then then we get a proper audience you
know we get we get a lot of people we'll
see how the next couple episodes like
we'll see what happens pan out yeah we
are planning in a couple more Corridor
crew pushes yeah and I think we can
strategize knowing now how the second
episode did without that yeah that'll
change how we approach the next two but
for me I mean I think if we're getting
40 000 views on something that has all
that effort and time from you and like
it's like I know it's not just about the
views but like
so much effort when we could be making
really cool YouTube videos for our
Channel and right have like a million
people see it and be able to learn from
it instead of just you know 40 000
people not that that's look that's an
awesome amount of people to watch and I
think all the comments are super
positive and that's awesome to
to hear but like
I don't think Netflix
knew what they were getting into when
they hired us I think we overachieved
for that channel yeah and but hey you
know what I don't think that's a bad
thing for four episodes I don't think so
I mean I think it's cool to like get be
like CD was here you know check out this
high quality content that's educational
fun you know
you'll walk away being enriched for it
from it hopefully
but like God I wish they'd just put it
on the actual platform so like people
could like see it yeah yeah yeah and see
it all at once yeah yeah I mean I just
don't know how much communication there
is between the Departments there yeah
that's true this is all part of the
marketing team so the budget and
everything else that came out of it
isn't part of their actual production
it's a totally separate it's a totally
separate department and it has totally
separate money allocated to it and if
that's the case then why didn't they
have us put it on our Channel because if
they're marketing and they want to get
eyes on their products
like hello yeah hello Netflix still
watching yeah yeah you're still watching
what you know what if you happen to make
the best point right there
I think that's truly from a marketing
standpoint yeah you want eyeballs
I don't feel like I'm in a position to
critique them too much though right now
considering we still have two episodes
to release yeah which are also really
great and people they're alive two
episodes are super good unless my true
episode is my favorite personal favorite
The Witcher episode yeah yeah but Freddy
directed the short film on the corporate
episode it's really good it's funny
that's great
um and The Witcher episode you know
Chris Cowan directed the short film on
that one and it's it's it's really great
Chris just made a short film that is
like a masterpiece in its own right yeah
it is like it feels perfect of all the
shorts yeah it's definitely the one that
could live on on its own without any
context yeah yeah you did such a great
job with that super excited for that
drop I think people really yeah yeah
so the thing though that I my where I'm
at with it is if we you know take a
similar amount of expected expense and
say we use green light on the
quarterdigital.com platform and then we
take some of that money and we put it
towards our own ideas
for example
Sam you remember this the bike theft
deterrent video
yes we have to make that that's such a
good idea
anti-science science videos basically
yeah the reason why we didn't do it
originally is because it was gonna cost
I did the I did the production budget on
it and it was going to cost like 45
Grand
but with utilizing the quarter digital
subscribers now we could justify that
expense and it would be an amazing video
and it would probably do really well and
it would we would harness the same types
of people and persons and strategies
that we did when we did punch for punch
but we could do it on our own channels
yeah it's a it's a whole thing though
like I still feel like the way we've
been pursuing it where we're always
trying to make multiple episodes you
know of everything we're putting on
there it's like that concept
think still is the best one in my
opinion because it's not like it's a
transaction anymore but you're like
you know when it's when you have a few
episodes of something it it's not just
like a piece of content so to speak but
it becomes this like living organism so
to speak where like
you have to be a part of that platform
to experience it rather than like uh
like a one-off expensive YouTube video
I don't know I don't know I think our
audience I mean let us know in the
comments but I think people would be
receptive to that and I think a lot of
people who are on well first of all we
already have two running shows that are
episodic and seasonal Encore or digital
you know we have crew cuts and we have
son of a dungeon yeah and we're going to
continue to do those and we can continue
to do serialized stuff on there and we
will but I think we are missing an
element of what we can do with that
platform creatively where
people are just interested in saying
like hey as a subscriber I hope to make
this cool video happen look at that it's
got 50 million views on YouTube isn't
that fun I was a part of that
I think people there's a I mean I might
be wrong but yeah it's the idea of like
yeah not green lighting things for the
website but for YouTube and so yeah I
think I think yeah we're also thinking
like hey we can't make this video but
for you know the help of the subscribers
which is isn't that why we created it
foreign
yeah definitely
um it's interesting just think about
that you know for a YouTube product
though you know yeah yeah I mean it
makes sense if that's what people I mean
put it on green light and see if that's
what people want to put their money to
you know I think that's what we need to
do we need to do that with a few ideas
yeah because there are like these videos
that we always toss around but it's like
ah dude this is just gonna be like
too much it's gonna be like four weeks
of work as opposed to like the two that
we're able to put in normally
so right yeah I mean
you guys will the the tribe will speak
right indeed croutons will tell us what
they want the croutons have spoken yes
we must make bike theft deterrent
featuring
yeah Sam does have a point though when
you bring a monthly subscription into
the mix here when you when you ask
people to pay for the content that
they're watching so there is something
to be said about a show that has
episodes that release you know on every
week or every other week and I just we
need to continue to do that bigger thing
that justifies the cost
um but hey you know that like it like we
said green light is the place where we
can decide if like you know people
really just want to see shows like that
or if there is I I'm sure there's a
place for those that show us here it's
like it just comes back down to like
this the same
practices we put into the group Channel
right now which is is the idea of this
consistency so to speak
you know and like when you start to
enter this realm of like all right well
we're hosting our own platform now
um you know well what's the transaction
there and it's it's like about um it's a
monthly transaction or yearly depending
you know but basically it's it's more
about the span of time than one
particular piece of content so to speak
so it's like cool let's say you really
want to watch this wacky video we made
right
but now you what the thing is we for
that we've transacted at least a month
of content so to speak there so now it's
like okay
like where's the consistency here it
says are we like
you know it's like that bike theft
deterrent thing it's like
sure there's many great ideas in the
world that could be one of them but if
like as operators of a platform like to
go down that path it's like we got a
green like one of those every month you
know it's like
or or find some level of like
consistency to the fact to to like
rather than thinking about it as like
hey there's one one great idea we want
to do but like how can we create that
consistency that like helps the platform
as like an organism so to speak like
perpetrate itself and like you know feel
like the value
you know persists yeah no and that's
that's totally it's a very wordy way of
saying I'm not suggesting I'm not
suggesting that we throw everything
we've done out the window I mean yeah we
have yeah great two great episodic
seasonal shows on there already
we can do more we will do more but I'm
all I also think
it's funny you guys are talking more as
the producers right now usually I'm in
the other I'm in your seat and you're in
mine but I'm thinking hey we now have
the opportunity to do some artistic
ideas that we haven't been able to do
yet yeah and and I think necessitating
them to fit into the box of well they
need to be serialized so that people can
get the True Value out of the platform I
think is as long as you have that still
and you're not you're not taking one or
the other
but you're doing both I think that
really starts to bring the platform into
what we hoped it could be which was
the ability to tell cool stories which
is all ultimately I think people who our
members want us to want to see us do
it's not totally A New Concept either I
mean dubstep gun's got green lit and
that's a one-off right just recorded
yeah that's a one-off and we talked
we're gonna release that on YouTube yeah
exactly so I mean yeah I guess it it's
in line but just doing it like as a more
crew Side Video definitely is a spin on
that I think people would want to see
that stuff
um I mean doing doing a continuation of
the punch or punch show is another idea
as well
um and that is serialized and that would
be very fit that would fit very well
within what and that would work there's
a lot of ideas we had when we were first
talking to Netflix and things that like
I've wanted to explore like the Clint
getting on lit on fire kind of format
that's where punch for punch originated
but like we have a lot of things
explosions squibs air Rams other kinds
of wire stunts like you know yeah tons
of stuff
guns yeah all that stuff like sure
there's so much that Netflix won't let
us do so yeah maybe I mean would we we'd
have to Rebrand the whole thing though
right
yeah I mean yeah obviously sure but
that's not that's not a big deal I know
I know I just kick for kick but I like
the intro so much
swoosh first
[Laughter]
yeah swing for swing yeah so there's all
sorts of kinds of attacks we could name
it
yeah there's all kinds of ways of
hitting something yeah combo attack what
about back to back back
yeah yeah
oh man and wait wait wait wait wait
here's an idea it's an action
performance show
and you take people and they go back to
back and but it's basically like a game
of horse where each person goes and then
they have to try to complete the trick
or the stunt that the last person who
went before them did and then if and
then they have a chance to go and you go
until someone gets hurt
you go and tell somebody somebody loses
well that's the thing it's like what
with their life so we get a drift car we
get trust Rod we have a shooting rally
all on one field
oh yeah
stunt Dome is a good freaking idea dude
I'm telling you that's like a futuristic
dystopian show where you have like these
like buff superhumans that can like leap
over everything and then the unwashed
masses have to recreate them or else
they die
no not like that don't make it all
dystopian no I'm making it funnier and
better now only the strongest as a
narrative no you do this in real life
and it's and you don't you cut out the
you know masses part dying
what happens you just don't show it
everyone else is just a regular person
yeah
versus these like
buff Megaton people American shrimp
Academy it's just
a competition of stuntmen and then they
get eliminated once they get all the
letters of the word
yeah and the word is the word is stunt
Dome
there's a lot of letters
we come up with a better word but stunt
Dome is definitely the name of the show
for sure
oh my God maybe we should put that one
out on green light that would be super
funny yeah dude spin off a punch for
punch that nobody asked for
yeah we could do a series where we
put hashtag stunt dome in the comments
let us know stunt them should be with
real stunt people or if it should be
like squid game but with instead of
dastardly tricks it's just super buff
people yeah hurricanes yeah like the tug
of war one where it's like a bunch of
people playing tug of war over a pit you
know yeah
versus like these dystopian uh Koreans
who are like in this trapped in this
like yeah a post-capitalist like yeah
circus hellscape you know whatever
that's awesome and they just drag them
into this [ __ ] yeah they just they lose
every time it's like not even a
competition
they just lose
it's there's no Stakes no drama
they just die man
we're actually bringing a face to this
punishment
all right so it sounds like there's some
Superior breed of humans
oh God it's all in our attempt to
breathe superhumans for our first stunts
sorry sorry I'm taking this far too too
much
what is a team one is a dystopian
narrative a la squid game and the other
one is an action show it reminds me of
like righteous gemstones where you have
you watched that yeah it's like yes
they're like Ultra Christian buff boys
sweaters yeah they have white sweaters
and gold cross chains dressed in linen
white linen oh yeah I love it it's so so
great yeah it is really good Man Battle
of the mega churches yeah yeah it's so
good like like the mall Church hilarious
the church in the mall where his other
freaking like Uncle was yeah
eating mega churches who can freaking
okay
we can franchise stunt Dome out and you
can have like church stunt Dome and like
mosques yeah the battle of the religion
school stuff is already a thing though I
think school stuff yeah they've been
doing that for a few years
yeah
for gangs for games yeah
you up
street gang stunt Dome cartel Mafia
stunt Dome we got it all we've done
stunt driving but we haven't done stunt
Drive buys
yeah too soon
who's someone who's gang adjacent like
VFX the stunts you know
you have your actual OG who's on one
side and then yeah Danny Trejo
well yeah I don't used to be in a gang
yeah hosted by Trejo yeah something like
that posted by Snoop Dogg and Danny
Trejo yeah or no it's like just a
regular delinquent normal
delinquent and this other guy is Owen OG
[ __ ]
head to Lincoln
trouble he's like yeah it costs Rubble
we'll put cherry bombs and toilets
pipes
[Laughter]
I took a few extra peppermints once
I filled my whole Pockets with
peppermints one time
[Laughter]
and money and wallets but yeah I'm gonna
need that I can't do the hang of this
yeah
and at the end of this episode we're
going to do our very own crime
you're the hosts are Danny Trejo Snoop
Dogg and Martha Stewart and Nico the
Stewart is good and Nico
Martha Stewart and to talk about like
tax fraud
the invisible crime
oh
my God what would that be wrong she may
not look like a criminal yeah shot for
shot
don't be alarmed for shame good for hood
dude
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
yeah yeah you have one of the one of the
intros via carjacking yeah yeah we're
gonna teach you how to check
all right so this is the training day
um that's our first foyer at 4A and then
the next iteration is the criminal
version It's called cut Dome
oh boy oh no oh my God man we're getting
wacky well hopefully uh Netflix doesn't
watch this podcast
yeah dude they would love this they
would love this conversation
we're so cool yeah
totally I think that's I think that's
what we gotta do let's let's put it on
green light and see what happens
yeah there'll be some waivers involved
worse yeah oh yeah
uh like the Mr Beast prison prison
episode oh yeah
blow back I didn't hear about it
everybody get
it everyone's volunteered he he had a
guy stay in a self-containment or a
isolation cell uh and every day that he
chose to stay there he got like x amount
of money and people were you know
decrying it because they were like
that's inhumane it's like well the guy
chose to stay there and he could have
left at any time
literally like the opposite of what
presents like right exactly
you're actually gaining something right
right
so yeah
um there'll be some blow back but we'll
get through it it'll be fine yeah yeah
yeah yeah they're always little broken
bones
yeah
skins that's what Innovations sharp
things
um but seriously if you if you if you're
listening to this and you don't have any
thoughts on what you'd like to see
especially if you're on the platform let
us know I'll be reading all the comments
and and responding and checking it out
because uh it will help inform us we're
looking to the fall to do some new ideas
um for for shows and for even for videos
and stuff so it'll be informative to see
what you guys have to say
yeah
yeah yes sir
um okay anybody got any other amazing
Revelations to uh let out on this
podcast before we uh close it up here
I'm just fired up about stunts now dude
yeah man yeah shank for shank coming
soon
let's do some crime pranks dude
yeah
you guys know about like truth pranks
too like when you tell someone something
else and oh you just say yeah yeah it's
also called alive but alive yeah sure oh
truth pranks are lies definitely oh wow
yeah that's true that's a revelation for
you right there we should just do a
truth prankster series next yeah but hey
we'll let you guys hey we're the truth
pranks all right y'all thanks for
watching everybody I'm gonna play us out
thanks for joining me and uh guys and uh
I hope everyone's having a great day see
you later see you later
all right
[Music]
we're waving at Jake but we should
really be waving at our own individual
cameras
please cut it